so mexico city is a place
of paradoxes of conundrums
and of water that it's there but you
don't see it
there's parts of the cities where you
would never know just by looking at them
that there's any water crisis around
they have clean water
24 hours a day apparently just as
abundant as it would be in new york or
something like that
then you have other parts of the city
where people
are living in very very extremely
precarious water situations
low-income parts of mexico city and the
people that live around it
are now facing a situation where they
open the tap and no water comes out
it's a very tragic story of having all
of the water in the world
and somehow ending up being a city that
today is on the list of top 10 cities
most likely to run out of water
you have to do something and so we do
enrique lomnes's hometown
mexico city is in a water crisis that
gets worse by the day
he started social enterprise isla urbana
to stem the tide
they design and build cheap and simple
systems that catch and clean
rain water there's nothing new about
rainwater harvesting people have been
harvesting rainwater since they first
opened their mouths and looked up at the
sky at the same time it seemed to us
like a logical thing
just figure out how we can use this
water that we have available to us as
kind of like a first
part of a larger solution
it's a situation that affects women very
particularly mostly it's women who tend
to be
more kind of in charge of of managing
the household
and basically their lives start you know
circling around
these water issues
elizabeth is one of 11 people living in
this house on the edge of mexico city
she's also one of two and a half million
people who don't have access to
permanent
and safe drinking water
but going thirsty isn't where elizabeth
and her family's problems end
the economic implications of not having
water are very interesting and people
that rely on water trucks
for example they often have to have
somebody at home
all the time to wait for a possible
water truck arrival so there's often
someone that can't work at all they just
need to always be at home
what's strange about mexico city though
is it isn't some barren desert
it's wet really wet
here we'll have one hour where it just
it's like apocalyptic the sky is just
falling and there's
lightning and thunder and rivers in the
streets during the rain season
you will have floods those floats can
last
for days mexico city gets considerably
more rain than a city like london does
for example
the question that comes to one's mind is
if we have so much water resources
why do we have to be in such a bad
situation
the water crisis in mexico city is you
know a 400 year old story mexico city
started off
being a city on an island in the center
of a lake in this basin
high up in the mountains and over the
course of 400 years
basically the city has focused on
draining all of these
ancient lakes out of the aquifer and
building
a giant modern city in its place so
where you had this
2000 square kilometer lake you now have
just city as far as the eye can see you
see
a lot of highways and a lot of avenues
and streets
who have the name of rivers those
streets were actually rivers 50
60 years ago to provide for its vast
population
around 1800 wells pump water out of the
ground
depleting the aquifer below but because
the city is prone to deadly flooding
it's built a massive infrastructure to
get the water out quickly when it rains
the result not enough water filters down
to recharge the aquifer
the loss of that water that you can
actually see
is paralleled with the drying up of all
of the aquifers we're just pumping and
pumping and pumping water out of the
ground
to the degree that actually mexico city
is is physically sinking
more than 10 meters in the last century
monuments need steps added for people to
reach them
streets rise and fall sinkholes open up
the earth
and the water from the ground isn't
enough to quench the city's thirst
thirty percent of its water is imported
from outside the city
but the infrastructure is so old and
huge not only is 40
of water lost through leaks but much of
what does make it
can become contaminated many people end
up spending a significant portion of
their income
on expensive bottled water
people don't trust the quality of the
water they get out of the grid even in
areas where it's actually quite good
98 or so percent of the population
doesn't drink tap water
they buy water from purifiers from these
like filter stores that will fill your
your like five gallon jugs
we're industrial designers and we were
honestly looking for problems to solve
people just started telling us about
water
they started telling us about how their
water situation was getting worse and
worse
isla urbana installed their first system
here in the usco
on the southern edge of the city it
didn't take long for people to realize
the benefits
little by little almost all of the
neighbors have uh
have started harvesting rainwater
themselves
we're working with communities so that
they can become self-reliant
in getting their own water supply and
securing their own water
it needs to be as simple as possible
rain falls on the roof
goes through the gutters goes through
the pipe diverts the first volume
goes into a tank gets chlorinated you
let the
little bits of dust settle and then you
pump that water out and give it just
some
simple filtration that water you can
just connect directly into your house's
existing plumbing system so you open the
tap in the kitchen and that's the rain
water that's coming out
for families in these areas that are
very very water stressed
starting to harvest rain water can mean
sometimes doubling the amount of water
that you
actually have available 95 or so of the
water that's used in a household
is not for drinking it's for everything
else and so that's really where you want
to hit
first because that's where you're going
to make the biggest first difference so
we want to have our baseline system be
as affordable as possible
but designed in such a way that you can
add new like treatment
systems to it so that you can eventually
stop having to buy
drinking water as well the water it's
it's water except
it's just water that's reaching your
house via falling on you from the sky
instead of coming from the city's water
grid
[Music]
[Music]
we get usually between 700 and 1000
liters
of water per year for every square meter
of roof
so if you have a house that has say a
hundred square meter roof
it's not it's not a a huge house at all
it's that house like that can get
up to around 100 000 liters of water per
year the problem at that point becomes
they just don't have enough tanks to
store it all
mexico city should be able to get at
least 20 to 30 percent of its water
demand through rainwater harvesting
systems
which is very significant it's
an incredible amount of water
guaranteeing water goes way beyond
quenching thirst and saving money
it could also save a city from itself
you have
health economic social political
problems if you divide the amount of
water
that gets into the network every
second every inhabitant of mexico city
should get 350 liters per day
if the entire eastern part of mexico
city runs out of water there's going to
be incredible amounts of social friction
and discontent and political crises
we all live in this valley we all need
to be okay
the local government has recognized the
perilous position the city finds itself
in
and last year invested in ten thousand
of isla ubana's systems
they plan to install a hundred thousand
by 2024.
tiene
[Music]
many believe regenerating areas of
nature holds the key to protecting
cities from problems like water
sustainability
we are not going to be able to return to
the aztec city
in the middle of the lake that that's
gone
but we can have a new water model
for the city a model where we keep
water we have rivers we have small lakes
and water can be a friend and an
ally and not a foe like it's today
when it comes to running out of water
mexico city
isn't alone la cape town sao paulo
the list is growing each with millions
of inhabitants facing devastating water
crises
they're serving as a warning as more of
the globe's population migrates to urban
centers
mexico city in 1940 had maybe a million
and a half inhabitants and today has
close to 23 million people and this
incredibly violent growth now this
incredibly fast expansion of the city
has put unbelievable stress on all of
the natural systems that provide us with
things like water
since 2009 isla robana have installed
more than 20
000 of their harvesting systems mostly
on top of low income homes in mexico
city
and in rural communities their devices
catch a combined 800 million liters of
water each year
providing some 120 000 people with a
significant portion of their water needs
i believe a lot in the empowerment
aspect of this
how do we transition to being a society
where everybody is actively
participating in water management and is
actually harvesting their own water and
taking care of it and not relying on
this other
foreign
you